we're already familiar with the idea of
a polynomial and we spent some time
adding polynomials subtracting
polynomials and multiplying polynomials
and factoring polynomials and what we're
going to think about in this video and
really start to think about in this
video is the idea of polynomial division
so for example if I had the polynomial
and this would be a quadratic polynomial
let's say x squared plus 3x plus 2 and I
wanted to divide it by X plus 1 pause
this video and think about what would
that be what would I have to multiply X
plus 1 by to get x squared plus 3x plus
2 well one way to approach it is we
could try to factor x squared plus 3x
plus 2 and we've done that multiple
times in our lives we think about well
what two numbers add up to 3 you know if
I were to multiply them I get 2 and the
one that might jump or the ones that
might jump out at you are 2 and 1 and so
we could express x squared plus 3x plus
2 as X plus 2 times X plus 1 and then
all of that is going to be over X plus 1
and so if you were to take X plus 2
times X plus 1 and then divide that by X
plus 1 what is that going to be well
you're just going to be left with and X
plus 2 this is going out you have to put
parentheses this is going to be an X
plus 2 and if we want to be really
mathematically precise we would say hey
this would be true as long as X does not
equal X does not equal negative 1
because if x equals negative 1 in this
expression or this expression we're
going to be dividing by 0 and we know
that leads to all sorts of mathematical
problems but as we see for any other X
as long as we're not dividing by 0 here
this expression is going to be the same
thing as X plus 2 and that's because X
plus 2 times X plus 1 is equal to what
we have in this numerator here now as we
go deeper into polynomial division we're
going to approach things that aren't is
easy to do just purely through factoring
and that's where we're going to have
technique called polynomial long
division polynomial long division
sometimes known as algebraic long
division and if it sounds familiar
because you first learned about long
division and fourth or fifth grade it's
because it's a very similar process
where you would take your X plus one and
you would try to divide it into your x
squared plus three X plus two and you do
something very and I'm going to do a
very quick example right over here but
we're going to do much more detailed
examples in future videos but you look
at the highest degree terms you say okay
I have a first degree term and a second
degree term here how many times does X
go into x squared well it goes x times
so you put the X in the first degree
column and then you multiply your x
times X plus one x times X is x squared
X times one is X and then you subtract
this from that so you might already
start to see some parallels with the
long division that you first learned in
school many years ago so when you do
that these cancel out 3x minus X we are
left with a 2x and then you bring down
that 2 so 2x plus 2 and they say how
many times does X go into 2x well it
goes two times so you have a plus 2 here
2 times X plus 1 2 times X is 2x 2 times
1 is 2 you can subtract these and then
you are going to be left with nothing 2
minus 2 is 0 2x minus 2x is 0 so in this
situation it divided cleanly into it and
we got X plus 2 which is exactly what we
had over there now an interesting
scenario that we're also going to
approach in the next few videos is what
if things don't divide cleanly for
example if I were to add 1/2 x squared
plus 3x plus 2 I would get x squared
plus 3x plus 3 and if I were to try to
divide that by X plus 1 well it's not
going to divide cleanly anymore you
could do it either approach one way to
think about it if we know we know can
factor x squared plus 3x plus 2 is say
hey this is the same thing as x squared
plus 3x
plus two plus one and then all of that's
going to be over X plus one and then you
could say hey this is the same thing as
x squared plus three X plus two over X
plus one over X plus one plus one over X
plus one plus one over X plus one and we
already figured out that this expression
on the left as long as X does not equal
negative one this is going to be equal
to X plus two so this is going to be
equal to X plus two but then we have
that one that we weren't able to divide
X plus 1 into so we're just left with a
1 over X plus 1 and we'll study that in
a lot more detail in other videos what
does this remainder mean and how do we
calculate it if we can't factor a part
of what we have in the numerator and as
we do our polynomial long division will
see that the remainder will show up at
the end when we are done dividing we'll
see those examples in future videos